did that guy suck for all of you you're
first you're a second did he suck for
you yeah he didn't even look at me yeah
that's true I came here when I was 10
but I've been meeting all kinds of
people in America right we sucked for
you because you said something I said
you look like you read a lot of books
um yeah I wish I was reading one right
now I don't know what I did deserve this
hostility but uh just trying to have a
good time here just a comedy show you
know what I mean dude I asked him a
question and he rolled his eyes I was
like what do you [ __ ] my
I don't have to put up with this from
you you [ __ ]
how do you guys know each other can I
ask are you comfortable talking about if
not it's all good we can move on
you met on hinge
yeah dude the south is more open-minded
than you think don't be so nervous you
know what I mean there's some [ __ ]
that you're not nervous
what are you
tell me what emotion you're feeling
he's confused by Indians as a Brit I
don't think he is to be honest with you
[Applause]
freedom
and I'm trying to power through the set
but when I'm done with my set and I see
him doing this
that [ __ ] there is no way you're [ __ ]
left hand is more interesting than what
we're doing up here for an hour
hopefully we want to go home on
sitting here picking his [ __ ]
calluses on his hand for 10 minutes just
go he's a [ __ ] and then I just [ __ ]
lost it I was like all my jokes [ __ ]
this guy he deserved it I don't know if
we put this out because it's so mean but
he [ __ ] deserves it's fun to be
honest with you I had a good time how is
this more polite than just getting up
and walking out
I think he's funnier than me
[ __ ] Brits dude
I'm so glad that [ __ ] died so glad
that's my life this whole time I didn't
care I was like whatever 92 year old
[ __ ] died who cares what she did to
India I'm over it I'm not over it
anymore
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
ah
you get those jokes don't you you don't
have a hard time understanding that
[ __ ] stupid inbred [ __ ] [ __ ] you
hate this [ __ ] now and it's your fault
I wish we could dump more tea in a
[ __ ] hurricane right now
Tea Party part two
in a much less significant state
son I swear to god dude
I swear to God if I had a [ __ ] glove
I slap you like that with that [ __ ]
challenge you to a duel
[Applause]
person to be honest with you I feel so
good though
I feel so much better about everything
[ __ ] the queen
you goofy inbred [ __ ] that killed Diana
[ __ ] you
oh I do you feel bad for this Diana
killing ass [ __ ] really
miss you seem very sweet I I don't want
you to feel bad about yourself but do
you really feel bad about this Diana
killing ass [ __ ] can you do me a favor
can you just come sit here for five
minutes just look at this guy can you
see him from here you only see this part
of his face you don't see the shitty
part it's right here you paid for the
[ __ ] I bet he wouldn't do this if he
paid
remember what I said about being
disrespectful [ __ ] all of it
how about the window
respect is given when respect is taken
or whatever the [ __ ] is uh it's a
reciprocity is more I'm goddamn looking
for I'm not here sound like
[ __ ] suffering succotash out
here
I'm out here talking like Daffy Duck I'm
so upset at this [ __ ] guy
I just don't get it
there's not some [ __ ] dry ass BBC
sitcom
you couldn't stay at home watched Mr
Bean on PBS on Saturday night
[ __ ] foreign
God damn dude
you know I swear to God I usually tell
people I want to move to London
I changed my mind just now
I love London you can't be from London
you're too where are you from and I
don't give a [ __ ] I'm asking I'm like
you're gonna answer me
I'm sorry I ruined your night truly I'll
never feel bad for you in my life
that was the worst thing I said I feel
like I did okay then
how about this I wish the queen was
Hindus so I could watch that [ __ ] burn
to death how about that
take that dead body and light it on fire
like a [ __ ]
[Applause]
help of her next life she comes back as
a minority [ __ ] [ __ ] miserable
[ __ ] frigid [ __ ] get out of here I
might give a [ __ ]
I'm looking for my seven foot camera guy
around the corner like just in case this
guy charges the stage
hey thank you bro
you're not even scared of your size he's
just not used to black people yeah
[Applause]
I'm having fun now guys